sunshine
[Music]
Rihanna takes flight during the Super
Bowl halftime show
draped in red rereads a sight to see
flying over State Farm Stadium
[Music]
belting out her 2012 chart topper
diamonds
like diamonds
[Music]
just trying to shine bright like a
diamond like her how's this run been for
you and what does it mean to you you
know it really feels Like A lot's
happening all at once it feels like
motherhood Oscar Super Bowl
I'm still pinching myself yeah the
Navy's pinching themselves too after
Rihanna's baby bump reveal E.T confirms
she's expecting baby number two with
boyfriend ASAP Rocky the Super Bowl is
one of the biggest stages in the world
and a new mom nothing would have gotten
me out the house if it wasn't a
challenge like that
[Music]
will be happy the set list was the
biggest challenge that was the hardest
hardest part you're trying to cram
17 years of work into 13 minutes so it's
it's difficult but I think we did a
pretty good job at narrowing it down
Rihanna capped off her big night with
diamonds so let's hope Kevin Hart placed
his bets elsewhere you know what I'm
gonna say diamond first song
[Music]
diamonds in the sky
foreign
[Music]